I have a question well what's that why  given every other possible option  doesn't match was the life of a paid  assassin well it was that or the  priesthood  you've got a secret  something you can't tell anyone because  you don't trust anyone look around you  James  everything you believed in a room  welcome James it's been a long time  now finally here we are the first thing  you should know about us incidentally we  have people everywhere you don't have to  worry about me  this organization you know it's cool  it's name is Spectre there's not one  person and my sexy isn't talking about  it about what that you're finished  recently I think you're just getting  started  you